you're right you're right you're right
Prince Harry was emotional at the end of
it and as I think anyone would be it is
an incredibly grueling experience being
cross-examined he's you know yesterday
he was in the box for over five hours it
was a little less today but a very
exhausting experience nonetheless
um and of course for Prince Harry he
knows that it's not just the eyes of the
courtroom on him it is the eyes of the
world's media every Nuance of his body
language is going to be analyzed and
poured over and this case doesn't just
impact Prince Harry it does impact the
royal family my sources tell me that the
king and the prince of Wales were very
wary about Harry going into the witness
box and I think when you see what's come
out in Harry's evidence and his witness
statement you can understand why Prince
William clearly didn't want it out in
the public domain that he'd accepted a
settlement from NGM Rupert Murdoch's
news Empire when in fact we learned
today that he accepted a settlement we
understand of a million pounds and to
settle out of court
um over phone hacking and it's these
sort of details that the royal family
really don't want to come out and of
course with further cases on the horizon
and who knows what else is going to be
revealed about the family and their
relationship with the press something
that we know Harry's very keen to
explore publicly when is QC David
Sherman asked him how it had been being
in the witness box and and undergoing
this sort of forensic questioning Harry
did seem quite choked up and uh he said
it's been a lot and I think anyone
watching the proceedings will will
understand why it has been a very
intensive
um and grueling interview the hardest
interview probably of his entire life
this was never going to be a walk in the
park but I suspect even Harry perhaps
wasn't prepared for the intensity of
being cross-examined the fact that he
sort of appeared very emotional I don't
think there's anything fake about that I
think anyone going through what he's
been through would be relieved exhausted
and frankly elated that the whole thing
is over of course until then next court
case you know how's that going to play
to the judge to see him being
cross-examined in court to go over all
of those historical articles was clearly
an exhausting and at points quite
difficult and painful experience for him
I did speak to a Salisbury close to
Prince Harry who says that he thinks
this has gone well he's feeling very
optimistic he's he's he's quite
confident that he's going to have
success and if you look at his track
record and both he and Megan who who
have taken on newspapers in the past
that you know they've got a pretty good
track record of winning so Harry's
feeling positive he's very pleased that
he's done this you know he has made this
his life's Mission and I'm told this
isn't about the money it isn't about
settlements and it is about doing his
best but I think it's also about Harry
wanting to change the Tabloid landscape
I think many people will be questioning
whether that's actually his role to do
so but he has made it his life's mission
to change the media landscape
[Music]